the supreme court says shoring up voting
procedures isn't racist
nicole hannah jones gets her tenure and
then demonstrates why she shouldn't have
been offered it in the first place
and nancy pelosi launches her january
6th commission with cover from liz
cheney i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn
so should you visit expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first a reminder you're spending
way too much on your cell phone bill
pretty much everybody is unless you
switch over to pure talk usa which is
why so many of my listeners already have
in fact another thousand of you my
extremely wise listeners
have made the switch from your
overpriced wireless carrier to pure talk
over the past couple of months
so what exactly are the rest of you
waiting for if you're with a t verizon
or t-mobile your family could save over
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers
you can even keep your phone and your
number but you will be saving a fortune
pure talk is the top-rated wireless
company by consumer affairs they've got
the absolute best customer service team
based right here in america
if that sounds good it gets better
because right now you get unlimited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month now you might be thinking
what if i use eight gigs of data here's
the thing they're not going to charge
you for using
data over that six gig limit grab your
mobile phone dial pound 250 and say ben
shapiro to get started when you do you
say 50
off your very first month dial pound 2 5
zero say keyword
ben shapiro go check them out right now
again dial pound 250 say ben shapiro get
started with pure talk pure talk is
simply
smarter wireless okay so yesterday was a
day of panic panic
because the supreme court of the united
states held that the voting rights act
which is a very very
far-reaching and historic measure in
american law going all the way back to
1965 it was designed
to prevent attempts to essentially
keep the vestiges of segregation in the
south after the civil rights act and
prevent black people from voting it was
meant to stop
those procedures from happening in the
south that required southern states
particularly to go through a process
known as pre-clearance
in which their voting laws were
basically pre-cleared by the federal
government and the idea was that over
time
as the country got less racist and as
states began to see better
representation
of black voters who historically had
been
discriminated against the polls that the
voting rights act would start to
diminish over time in the same way that
we saw the supreme court say in the
1970s that affirmative action would
would start to wane over time and this
has always been
sort of dicey constitutional territory
because on its face the voting rights
act
does seize authority from the states and
bring it up to the level
of the federal government and so the
broader the more broadly you interpret
the voting rights act the more
permanently you interpret the vote more
the voting rights act more teams to come
into conflict with the constitution
the same thing happens to hold true with
regard to affirmative action as the
supreme court has found over and over
they keep saying well
it's sort of a temporary measure yeah we
understand that it violates the equal
protection clause
but we need it in order to redress
historic wrongs and
and now the supreme court has come up
with sort of new justifications for why
it's okay to discriminate
in admissions on the basis of race now
they say diversity is its own excuse
and all this well the voting rights act
was never meant to
be a way of cramming down federal rules
on
on states that had discriminated for all
of time we are now 60 years removed
from the voting rights act almost 60
years removed because past again in 1965
it is now almost 2025 so it's almost
three generations later
and the left is still insisting that
voter discrimination
is a massive problem in the united
states the evidence of this is extremely
scanty the notion that black and
hispanic voters in the united states but
particularly black voters are being
discriminated against and prevented from
voting
is just not true okay then the the
belief
that huge numbers of black voters are
being disenfranchised as they lie it is
trotted out by the democratic party
in order to jog voter turnout in the
black community
the reality is that barack obama
basically won in 2012 because
black voters in places like ohio showed
up in numbers that out tallied the
percentage of the population
the reality is that black voters showed
up on mass this last election cycle in
places like georgia for example
so the the belief that red states have
been shutting the doors to black voters
or discriminating against black voters
is extremely un it's just not based in
evidence it really is not based on
evidence at this point
okay so there was a voter law in arizona
it was passed in 2018
and what it cracked down on is
essentially two things one was voting
out of precinct
and if you voted outside your precinct
then your ballot got tossed
because you have usually a place where
you're supposed to vote
and it's very difficult to match you up
to your vote if you're voting outside
your precinct if i drove
over to naples today and i decided i was
going to vote in naples as opposed to
voting where i live well then that would
be a serious problem it'd be difficult
to match up my ballot to the place where
i lived
and so arizona cracked down on that and
they also crack down on the most corrupt
practice in modern american politics
ballot harvesting ballot harvesting
is this practice where you deploy
members of your party to go pick up
ballots
from third parties so you are the
republican party chairman and you say i
to your worker i want you to only go to
houses that have historically voted
republican i want you to pick up their
ballots and i want you to drive them
to the ballot box hey well this presents
a couple of problems one
basically whichever side is better
funded in terms of who picks up more
ballots that day
is going to win because you just walk up
to the door you say oh did you forget to
vote today you don't go to the next door
neighbor say oh did you forget to vote
today well
i'm here to help you vote today two
is it really a stretch of the
imagination to believe that when you
ballot harvest
on behalf of a party and you're a party
activist and you have access to a bunch
of ballots that you have specifically
picked up
they're not going to go in the back and
just mark off a few boxes in fact this
is a major problem
in north carolina in a republican
district somebody hired a republican
voter outfit and this is exactly what
they did they had to rerun the election
okay so so ballot harvesting has been a
major problem it's been a major problem
in california
in 2018 for example democrats swept a
bunch of seats in orange county
that looked as though they were red
seats specifically because they went out
and they ballot harvested so ballot
harvesting is extremely corrupt it is
rife with the potential for fraud and
arizona cracked down on it
so the democrats sued they said that it
was a discriminatory law they said it
violated the voting rights act because
it prevented black and hispanic people
from voting in a way that it didn't
prevent white people from voting now the
problem for them
is that it was a facially neutral law
that will apply to everybody you can't
vote out of precinct it doesn't matter
your race
and the other problem is that
everybody's still got to vote
so it's very difficult to make the claim
that this was specifically directed at
black and hispanic voters
you could say that it was attempting to
crack down on democratic voting
practices in which they had an advantage
that ballot harvesting had been used to
great advantage by democrats and
republicans were now fighting back
against that
but that's not unusual right that is
true throughout american voting law
whenever democrats take control of the
legislature they preceded gerrymander
the entire state in alignment with
democratic voting interests and when
republicans take
advantage of of the legislature then
they do the exact same thing they
proceed to reverse gerrymander
so the sort of interplay over voting law
has been a long time feature of american
politics none of that is banned
right changing voting procedures such
that it seems to help your party in one
way or another i mean this is what
democrats are now attempting to do at
the federal level right there's a reason
why democrats are pushing
ballot harvesting in both the state and
the federal level and republicans are
pushing back against it and it's not
because democrats just want more people
to vote
i'm not seeing democrats really push
super hard in
highly red areas for ballot harvesting
for example it seems like they're doing
this
mostly on behalf of purple and blue
states
but the the the real ban is on voting
procedures that are designed
to disenfranchise black people that's
what the voting rights act is about so
the supreme court looked at the arizona
law and they said no this is this is not
violative of the voting rights act and
the descent in this particular is a 6-3
ruling in which all of the republican
appointees voted one way and all the
democratic appointees voted the other
it's the first kind of major 6-3 ruling
that
we've seen in a while because usually
roberts tends to vote with the democrats
on on sort of six three rulings
or he tries to water down the decision
so as to get a couple more democratic
votes which we've seen
a few times here unanimous decisions
that didn't have to be unanimous but
roberts made them unanimous and watered
down the decision in order to achieve
the unanimous vote and limit the scope
of the decision for example
okay on this one it went almost straight
party line appointment
and the democrats basically now claim
that any law that has quote unquote
disparate impact
is unconstitutional under the voting
rights act which is pretty wild because
most laws
have some sort of disparate impact it
turns out the desperate impact in this
particular case is my newt statistically
speaking
it doesn't matter okay so according to
democrats this is a racist
decision it is the it is the racist
republican majority on the supreme court
are cramming down a a violation of the
voting rights act of 1965
instead the supreme court should read
the voting rights act as broadly as
possible according to the descent in
order to rule out a huge bevy
of republican-led attempts to shore up
voting procedures that may
disproportionately
affect black and brown voters even
though they are facially neutral and in
fact neutrally applied
right this is the argument that you hear
from democrats until the last five
minutes that voter id is racist because
they say well you know that'll
disenfranchise more black and brown
people
and most americans like well no
everybody can go get an id but democrats
say well statistically fewer black and
brown people have
ids than white people therefore it's
discriminatory
that's the kind of logic that the
dissent uses written by elena kagan in
this particular supreme court case
because for democrats everything now
boils down to a core voter theory that
voter theory is the way they are going
to win future elections
is by cobbling together a coalition of
the supposedly dispossessed
to overcome the the fading white
majority
this has been a theory again it's the
most dangerous theory in american
politics the demography is destiny
it is a theory that is pushed
alternatively by the mainstream left and
the alt-right
it is a lie it is not true but democrats
have bought into this full scale because
it proposes
that as the country gets browner
inevitably democrats will not only win a
majority but they will keep a majority
no matter what
and that the majority will rule for all
time the demography is destiny argument
that democrats make
is basically a utopian argument it's a
millenarian argument we are going to
reach the end of history
at a point when we cobble together
enough of a coalition of the dispossess
that we will never lose another election
and thus the only thing that could be
preventing that right now is voter
suppression efforts on behalf of
republicans
which serves a couple of purposes one it
allows them to to keep this illusion
of the new politics in their mind and
two it allows them to lie to minority
voters and tell them that republicans
are attempting to
prevent them from voting in the first
place which of course is not true okay
so according to the new york times
the supreme court on thursday gave
states new latitude to impose
restrictions on voting
no they really didn't using a ruling and
a new case from arizona to signal that
challenges to laws being passed by
republican legislatures that make it
harder for minority groups to vote would
face a hostile reception from a majority
of the justices the new york times is so
unbelievably biased that is not what the
court says what the court says is if you
want to show discrimination in law you
have to show discrimination in law
you can't just allege that because a law
has a disparate impact
that means that the law itself is racist
every single law that has ever been
passed in the united states
affects some groups differently than
others every single law
that does not mean that the law is
invalid under either the civil rights
act or the voting rights act
and what what the dissent would like
what democrats would like is to have
essentially a super legislature at the
supreme court level that strike down
all laws made by red state legislatures
and green lights
all discriminatory measures taken by
blue state legislatures that really is
the goal here
the vote was six three the court's three
level three liberal members
in descent according to the new york
times the decision was among the most
consequential in decades on voting
rights it was the first time the court
had considered
how crucial part of the voting rights
act of 1965 applies to restrictions that
have a particular impact on people of
color but it doesn't have a particular
impact on people of color there's one of
the points that the majority opinion
makes
they say looking at this statistically
the impact on minority voters is is
minimal
justice samuel alito wrote for the
majority said where a state provides
multiple ways to vote
any burden imposed on voters who choose
one of the available options cannot be
evaluated without also taking into
account the other available means in
other words
if the state says you can vote 10
different ways and one of the ways
happens to have disparate impact there's
still nine other ways for you to vote so
you really can't say
that this one right here this right here
is designed
in order to prevent black and brown
people from voting meanwhile justice
elena kagan
wrote that ascension wherever it can the
majority gives a cramped reading to
broad language
but here's the point the broader the
language of the vra the more broadly you
interpret the language of the vra the
closer it comes to violating the
constitutional provision that states get
to run their own elections
if you are attempting to read the voting
rights act in order to give the federal
government
complete purview over all voting
procedures simply on the basis
of an extremely statistically minute
disparate impact
you're basically just getting rid of
state ability at all
to make its own voting procedures which
violates the constitution itself
justice kagan said that the court's
action was a devastating blow to the
nation's ideal says what is tragic here
is that the court has yet again
rewritten in order to weaken
a statute that stands as a monument to
america's greatness and protects
against its basis impulses what is
tragic is that this court has damaged a
statute
statute designed to bring about quote
the end of discrimination in voting
well again the statute was designed to
do that the statute has largely
accomplished it
and at a certain point you're going to
have to decide whether you just want to
be in control what what elena kagan and
the democrats would like is to be in
control of all voting procedures
on the federal level so
democrats are using this as an
opportunity to push the their their
equal
right to act their voting rights act
their new voting legislation
the john lewis act and that of course is
an unconstitutional piece of legislation
that federalizes all voting procedure
you can see the democratic agenda call
things racist
because if you call them racist then you
get to federalize the procedure
but that's not what this case is about
this case simply said that some pretty
basic voting requirements
having a slightly disparate impact over
the course of millions of voters does
not mean
that this thing was designed to be
discriminatory or in fact is a
discriminatory piece of law
i will go through a little bit more of
the decision in a second because it's
kind of important
because again the entire democratic case
these days seems to boil down to
everything i don't like is racist and
therefore give me control we'll get to
more of that in just one second first
if you're a business owner who's hiring
you probably face a lot of challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack sure you
could post your job to some job board
then all you can do is hope the right
person comes along
that's why instead you should try zip
recruiter for free at zip recruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with just one click then
zip recruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the very first day it's no wonder
over 2.3
million businesses have come to zip
recruiter for their hiring needs
we use zip recruiter here at the daily
wire it's one of the reasons that we
have excellent
employees like bradford who not only
does an excellent job helping to run the
show but also makes terrific
recommendations about me buying
boats as well as um as well as golf
machines while other companies overwhelm
you with way too many options zip
recruiter
finds you what you're looking for the
needle in the haystack right now you can
try zip recruiter for free
at this web address zip recruiter.com
wire once again remember go to this
unique place ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire okay so
the supreme court majority points out
that the
the section two of the voting rights act
is not supposed to be an unlimited
guarantee that the federal government
gets to run all voting procedure
the first the court according to the
court decision the court first construed
the current version of section two
in a case called thornburg versus
gingles which was a vote dilution case
where the court took its cue
from section two's legislative history
the court's many subsequent vote
dilution cases have followed the path
that gingles charted because the court
here considers for the first time
how section 2 applies to generally
applicable time place or manner voting
rules
it is appropriate to take a fresh look
at the statutory text in 1982
congress amended the language in section
2 that had been interpreted to require
proof of discriminatory intent by a
plurality of the court
in mobile versus bolden in place of that
language
section 2a now uses the phrase in a
manner which results in a denial or
abridgement of the right to vote
on account of race or color right it's
denying or bridging
on account of race or color right
because of race or color
then section 2b states that section 2 is
violated only
where the political processes leading to
nomination or election are not quote
equally open to participation by members
of the relevant
protected groups in that its members
have less opportunity than other members
of the electorate to participate
in the political process and to elect
representatives of their choice
in that section the phrase in that is
used to specify the respect
in which a statement is true thus equal
openness and equal opportunity are not
separate requirements instead
it appears the core of to be is the
requirement that voting be equally open
the statute's reference to equal
opportunity may stretch that concept to
some degree
to include consideration of a person's
ability to use the means that are
equally open but equal openness remains
the touchdown in other words if you have
the ability to vote
then the fact that you chose not to vote
in one way doesn't mean that you can't
vote in another way
another important feature says the court
is the totality of the circumstances
requirement
any circumstance that has a logical
bearing on whether voting is equally
open
and affords equal opportunity may be
considered okay then
they take a look at sort of how the
arizona law
applies here and what they point here is
that having to identify one's polling
place and then travel there does not
exceed the usual burdens of voting
in addition arizona made extensive
efforts to reduce the impact of the
out-of-precinct policy on the number of
valid votes ultimately cast
by sending a sample ballot to each
household that includes a voter's proper
polling location
the burdens of identifying and traveling
to one's assigned precinct are also
modest when considering arizona's
political processes as a whole
the state offers other easy ways to vote
which likely explains why out of
precinct votes on election day make up
such a small and apparently diminishing
portion of overall ballots cast
also the racial disparity in burdens
allegedly caused by the out-of-pricing
policy is small in absolute terms
of the arizona counties that reported
out of precinct ballots in the 2016
general election
a little over one percent of hispanic
voters one percent of african-american
voters and one percent of native
american voters who voted on election
day
cast an out-of-ballot precinct ballot
for non-minority voters the rate was
around 0.5 percent
a procedure that appears to work for 98
or more of voters to whom it applies
minority and non-minority alike is
unlikely to render a system unequally
open
that is simply true i mean at what point
do you start to say that a law's
disparate impact starts to look racist
not at the difference between one
percent and point five percent
i mean that literally means that 99 of
the black hispanic and native american
people who cast ballots
in this particular way in arizona and
again remember
that this is this is a very small number
of people
that that number is is obviously not the
difference between
one percent and point five percent is
obviously not going to be the big
difference maker here
okay but according to the court as long
as there's any as long as according to
the descent and according to democrats
as long as there is any distinction
in the outcome that means that racism
has happened
now what this is driven is of course the
the democrats who suggest that the
supreme court is a repository of racism
etc
so president biden tweeted out today's
decision by the supreme court
undercuts voting rights in this country
and um makes it all more crucial
to pass them for the people act
and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act to restom
and explain bit of voting protection our
democracy depends on it our democracy
does not depend on it
that man just got 80 million votes
that man just won a bunch of states
who's not supposed to win our democracy
absolutely does not depend on you
federalizing all voting procedures but
again
this is the this is the pitch this is
constantly the pitch
okay joy reid did the same thing she has
a violent blow against democracy
okay so let me just get this straight to
say that ballot harvesting is not
allowed in a state again it's a very
corrupt
fraud-ridden voting procedure and to say
that you have to vote in the precinct to
which you are assigned
this apparently is a threat to democracy
everything according to the left is a
threat to democracy
everything so long as they believe that
it's going to cut against them
that's the always and forever
it is truly amazing to me that we have
gone through six months
eight months of people going crazy over
donald trump suggesting
that the election was stolen stop the
steal that voter fraud decided the
election which is untrue
and the exact same people say that
widespread evidence of voter suppression
and racism and voting procedures remains
a pressing issue in the united states
there is less evidence of the latter
than there is of the former and there's
very little evidence either
here is joy reid saying what joy reid
does
in a 6-3 ruling written by samuel alito
the most reliably conservative justice
the supreme court dealt another violent
blow against democracy by upholding two
restrictive arizona voting laws
forbidding the collection of absentee
ballots by anyone other than family or
caregivers
and allowing the tossing of ballots
inadvertently cast in the wrong
precinct it's the latest notch in the
belt of chief justice john roberts
whose life's work really since his days
as an influential aide in the reagan
justice department
has been to destroy the landmark 1965
voting rights act
okay understand the voting rights act
was specifically designed for a time and
a place in the same way that many of the
provisions of the civil rights act were
designed for a time and a place and
affirmative action was designed for a
time and a place
now places in 1964 1965 america it was
not designed to suggest that every
voting procedure undertaken
in a red state in the south has to be
scrutinized by the federal government
three generations later okay but
this is a political argument it's not an
illegal argument what elena kagan would
like she says no standards in her
descent by the way
her dissent basically says whenever we
decide that we don't like a voting
procedure we will just say it violates
the vra and then we'll throw it out
and the court in this case said no you
actually have to show evidence that this
was designed in order to hurt black
people
the the tnc did not show that in this
particular case and thus the dnc lost in
this particular case this also means by
the way that the doj case that's being
brought against georgia on the basis of
their new voting procedures is likely to
be tossed
by the supreme court it also means by
the way that the
the john lewis voting rights act that
the democrats are pushing
probably would be found unconstitutional
in a wide variety of ways by the same
supreme court
the reason democrats are pretending to
be so upset about this of course is
because
again they want black and hispanic
americans to believe that there's an
entire party seeking to disenfranchise
them that is a lie
it is untrue but maybe they can make
political hay
well the sun shines because if
everything is racism you never have to
make an affirmative case
for your own actual political agenda or
explain why it is that your agenda keeps
failing black and hispanic people the
country over
okay so nicole hannah jones apparently
has now received
her tenure i know i was waiting with
with bated breath as well
now i said for a long time i've become
an accelerationist when it comes to
universities and colleges
when it comes to universities and
colleges i think that um
basically the the colleges should
embrace their most radical points of
view
they should enshrine them and then
everybody who recruits for business
should just start ignoring college
degrees we at daily wire
do not take college degrees into account
when it comes to hiring
right we'll hire if you have
qualifications if you have work
experience we will hire you whether you
went to high school whether they went to
college we don't care
we would be hypocrites to do anything
less my business partner jeremy bourne
never graduated from college
i was harvard law school cara
educational degrees are quite disparate
our business partnership remains intact
they have the very silly notion that if
you get a degree from the university of
north carolina that this somehow
qualifies you
to actually do anything in life if you
are
a a liberal arts major or somebody who
studied with nicole hannah jones is
absurd on its face
no by the way note going out to all
major republican donors to the
university of north carolina this is
where your money is going
understand that your money is now going
your donations all right you may love
the tar heels but
your donation is now going to pay nicole
hannah jones salary should think about
that before you sign the check
think about what you would wish to
subsidize with your dollars
okay nbc news reports in a 9-4 vote the
board of trustees the university of
north carolina at chapel hill on
wednesday approved tenure
for pulitzer prize-winning journalist
nicole hannah jones now nicole hannah
jones is a professional liar and
prevaricator
she has no academic credentials that
would qualify her for a tenure track
position at a major university she has
i'm not qualified for a tenure track
position at a major university and i
actually have more degrees than she does
if the vote wednesday after a closed
session comes after a controversy over
why hannah jones
was not offered tenure in her
appointment at the hussman school of
journalism and the answer is pretty much
no
one is offered tenure right off the bat
typically you are on tenure track and
then you earn tenure
but originally she was supposed to be
given tenure just straight off the bat
at the hussman school of journalism
which means you can't fire her ever
hannah jones said that wednesday's
outcome was about more than her of
course
of course because everything with hannah
jones is uh is about more than her
the fight is about ensuring the
journalistic and academic freedom of
black writers researchers teachers and
students you said we must ensure our
work is protected and able to proceed
free from the risk of repercussions and
we are not there yet really
it seems we're not there yet because
you're utterly unqualified to have ever
been offered this position
you lied in the 1619 project repeatedly
you treat people who disagree with you
academically like garbage
you're extraordinarily radical and yet
somehow you've not only
been celebrated by our culture you have
been handed basically the editorship of
the new york times now
as well as a 10-year track position not
10-year track a tenured position
at the university of north carolina it
sounds like your systemic racism is
working very poorly in the united states
i must say
it's working truly terribly because it
seems like the
institutions of the united states that
are most powerful are too busy honoring
call hannah jones to
simple questions like does she know what
the hell she's talking about by the way
nicole hannah jones again one of our
great racial geniuses
so she uh she did an interview in which
she explained that actually
racial violence is good nobody should be
surprised about this she celebrated
racial violence last year
in the middle of the pandemic when there
were riots happening in america's major
cities
people tweeted out that this were these
were the 16 19 riots and she basically
said i
i hope so the truth is nicole hannah
jones has been propagating
lies and misinformation for years i mean
nicole henry jones last year was
suggesting that violence in the streets
is a good thing
the civil rights movement leads to this
massive civil rights legislation
being passed the 64 civil rights act and
the 65 voting rights act
and at the same time urban ghettos all
across the north are going up
in flames people are having uprisings
and folks were so confused because
there's a
huge expansion of black rights happening
but they aren't doing anything
about the living conditions of black
people on the ground in northern cities
and those people realize that
non-violent protest was not going to
resolve the issues that they were facing
oh non-violent protest is not what
actually resolved the civil rights
movement it was actually giant riots in
major american cities which actually
as studies demonstrated according to
david shore who basically had its career
ended by people like nicole hannon jones
who decided he couldn't even mention
this
he pointed out that riots actually cut
against the interests of the people who
are rioting it turns out most americans
don't like rioters they're not fans
and it turns out that the watts riots
and the detroit riots it actually
not only inhibited racial progress in
those cities it actually emptied out
large parts of those cities in the first
place here's nicole henner john i mean
she's celebrating violence
right that's what she's doing on cbs
news and not only but
she's not just then right she's
celebrating and and then
you at least might have made the case
although it's hard to make the case that
racial violence in detroit in los
angeles was useful
at least in the 1960s there was a much
more solid basis for the notion that
america had systemic racism problems
considering that half the country
literally
enshrined racism and law this is the
same nicole hannah jones who said last
year that destroying property isn't
actually violent
it is disturbing to see property being
destroyed it is
disturbing to see people taking property
from stores
but these are things and violence is
when an agent of the state kneels on a
man's neck until
all of the life is leached out of his
body
destroying property which can be
replaced is not
violence and to put those things uh to
use the exact same language to describe
those two things i think
really um it's not
it's not moral to do that now give that
lady tenure that lady deserves tenure
one of the wisest voices on race in
america nicole hannah jones
uh of course she also lies about
policing generally right she's been
lying for years
saying that policing evolved out of
slave catching which of course is not
true
modern policing particularly in the
south and as you said in certain parts
of the northeast
actually evolved out of the slave
patrols
the slave patrols were put in place to
deputize
white americans to police enslaved
communities
to ensure that enslaved people were only
in the places they were allowed to put
down slave insurrections
and these slave patrols had the right to
stop and question
any black person enslaved or free whom
they deemed to be suspicious
okay that of course is not true as dan
mclaughlin writes at national review
to the extent that modern police forces
took over the job of enforcing racist
laws
that's because enforcing the laws is
what police do so if you don't like the
fact that they're racist laws then you
should really look to the legislature
but to suggest that
modern policing is an outgrowth of slave
catching patrols by civilians
is silly policing in some form has
existed for as long as there has been
civilization says mclaughlin it was
typically led by a few government
officers a sheriff a magistrate a
constable perhaps
a local feudal lord right you'll
remember that the sheriff of nottingham
is the bad guy in robin hood but the old
english tradition which came to the
american colonies relied heavily on
community
volunteers according to an article by
gary potter
okay the development of policing in the
united states closely followed the
development of policing in england
in the early colonies policing took two
forms it was both informal and communal
which is referred to as the watch or
private for-profit policing which is
called the big stick the watch system
was composed of community volunteers
whose primary duty was to warn of
impending danger
boston created a night watch in 1636 new
york in 1658 philadelphia in 1700
the night watch was not particularly
effective because watchmen often slept
or drank
on duty eventually the the major cities
created professional police forces
professional police forces find their
beginnings in france
employ jean's arms as far back as 1700
the creation of professional uniform
police departments can be traced to
british home secretary robert peel who
introduced them in london
in 1829 in fact bobby's rich as they're
known cops and in britain
are called that today after robert peel
all of this
is is the real root of american law
enforcement
the notion that this is vigilantes and
citizens lynch mobs
okay that that is not where the police
came from also nicole hannah jones is a
believer that the police are the real
problem for black americans which of
course is a lie
the reality of course is that when it
comes to policing in the united states
it was
dearth of police that led to originally
disparate crime statistics between black
and white americans as jane levy of
los angeles times has written the fact
is that white communities basically said
to black communities particularly in the
south you're on your own
if murder happens your communities we're
just not going to police it and that led
to these wildly disparate murder
statistics in white communities
versus black communities but again
nicole hannah jones victim of the
american system
tenured professor over at university of
north carolina and celebrated much belly
hood editor-in-chief
of the new york times and all of this
ties into the broader democratic
narrative everything i don't like is
racist
and everything that i do like is
racially progressive which is why you
see lori lightfoot for example
explaining that 99
of the criticism against her is racist
and sexist
nope you're just a really crappy mayor
there have been questions raised about
your your temperament and
your reaction to criticism tribune
editorial use the term
erasable how much of this do you think
might have to do with the fact that
you're a woman
and partic specifically a black woman
about 99 of it women and people of color
are always held to a different standard
i understand that i've known that my
whole life and
the tribune or whoever can write what
they want what i'm doing is
fighting for the residents of the city
okay so um again the generalized
democratic argument these days
seems to be that if you oppose anything
democrats do
it's because of racial discrimination
joy behar of course the id of the
democratic party she says the same thing
now about kamala harris says the reason
kamala harris is receiving criticism is
because she's a black woman
um no it's because she's a terrible
terrible politician
in fact the only reason that joe biden
chose her is because she is a black
woman he himself said this
here is joy behar trying to pretend that
kamala harris is a victim of american
racism
what's interesting is that this will be
used by the right wing to attack
the biden administration and isn't it
interesting that they go after a black
woman
they don't go after a white guy joe
biden as much because joe biden looks
like the base
on the right he looks like them so
that's hard for them till i get mad at
him because then they get mad at
themselves you say something like
psychological is going on there
oh thank you that's that's deep deep
deep thoughts there and deep thoughts
there from joy
if there's one thing we know it's that
republicans are never angry at white
people like you know harry reid
or for example bill clinton or maybe
like hillary clinton a white lady
obviously they only get mad at black
people obviously
alrighty coming up we're going to get
into the latest on the january 6th
commission which is the latest
democratic ploy an attempt to drive the
notion that republicans are
racist and all the rest we'll get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about your office needs okay so you
spend a lot of your day
in the office on a very uncomfortable
chair and just as you should have
a bed that makes sense for you so you
can sleep properly
you need a chair that not only makes
sense for you but it's like sitting upon
a cloud it's like god made this chair
it's unbelievable
the x chair it has you covered for your
office chair needs the extra can give
you a massage
while you're sitting at your desk it can
warm your back on cold mornings it can
cool you off
on hot days and basically it's like
sitting on a beach in barbados
while you are working the secret is not
only their patented dynamic variable
lumbar support which offers unbelievable
lumbar supports your lower back they now
have introduced elements featuring
cooling
heat and massage therapy imagine
regulating your body temperature and
getting massage therapy while sitting at
your desk
x-chair lmx cooling delivers heat and
massage technology directly to your core
helping to increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy all perks
that make working from home or the
office a joy
lmax even offers four different massage
modes and fast warming heat technology
for therapy
to your sore back extra prices are going
up july 12th for the first time in
two years beat the price increase right
now everybody in the office competes to
sit on the extra each and every day like
while i'm working it's over there in the
production room
they're basically fistfights every
morning as to who gets to sit on the
extra go to the xchairshapiro.com right
now it's xchairshapiro.com right now
that's the letter x
chair shapiro.com or call one eight four
four four x chair to get a hundred bucks
off your order
x chair has a 30 day guarantee of
complete comfort you can finance your
purchase for as little
as 30 bucks a month go to
xshareshapiro.com right now use code
xwheels for free
xwheelbladecasterschairshapiro.com
also it's that glorious time of the week
when i give a shout out to a dailywear
member today
it is josie bartelt on instagram who
clearly understands how to ace being a
mom with a house full of boys in this
picture
sharon's happy young sons are sporting
binoculars ear protection
and three examples of the world's most
elite and well-made chalice
the caption reads quote our boys staying
hydrated with the greatest beverage
vessel see that plane behind them we
were listening to the sounds of freedom
watching the blue angels hashtag leftist
tears tumbler excellent with that much
high octane freedom
those tumblers must have been
overflowing thanks for the pick thanks
for being
a daily wire member also this weekend
got something for you to listen to
the past is full of heroes many of their
stories remain unsung that is why we
started a new podcast called america's
forgotten heroes it brings to life the
legends that these brave men left behind
and the second episode
is available today this episode focuses
on the pioneer of blind flying and
recipient of the medal of honor jimmy
doolittle
who thundered into the tokyo skies
seemingly out of nowhere to lead an
airborne raid
designed to avenge the attack on pearl
harbor standing at only five foot six
jimmy doolittle smarts encouraged coward
over most he revolutionized
piloting as we once knew it his name may
be overshadowed by the raid he led but
it's worth remembering he wasn't just a
pilot he was a man who changed the world
subscribe now
to america's forgotten heroes on alpha
podcast it is now like a top five
podcast
right now on apple spotify or anywhere
else you might listen because the second
episode is out today friday july 2nd
one new action-packed episode drops each
day through the fourth of july weekend
and into next week for a total
of seven episodes as too many heroes
never receive the recognition they
deserve
sharing their stories with you on this
independence day holiday is our small
tribute
to their heroism if you like what you
hear leave a five star review that
always helps with the rankings
help share those incredible stories
thanks for listening thank you to the
heroes who made such an excellent
podcast possible you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
as part of the broader racial push the
democratic party is making of course
they are now pushing their january 6th
commission so this is a partisan
commission
nancy pelosi announced it yesterday she
got liz cheney to sign up for the
commission so that she could have a
veneer of bipartisanship liz cheney of
course voted for impeachment of
president trump
uh and has been a long-time critic of
trump the problem with the january 6
commission of course is that
the basic premise of the january 6th
commission usually a congressional
commission is about what congress can do
you're not just supposed to hold
commissions on random crap i understand
that we do commissions on random crap
now like we'll have a steroids in
baseball commission for no apparent
reason
but congress theoretically is supposed
to hold commissions and investigations
with regard to legislation
or procedures they can shore up instead
it appears that what this commission is
designed to do pretty obviously
is to keep january 6 the forefront in
people's minds and to link it to broader
supposed republican ideologies of
bigotry
because again if your entire political
party is dependent on casting
the opponent as bigoted you're gonna use
whatever you can find in order to do
that january 6th
is is what nancy pelosi wishes to you
she made that absolutely clear yesterday
testimony from the department of
homeland security
about concerns that are out there all of
these
institutions talking about
well i hate to even go there but it's
what they have said
in terms of white supremacy
anti-semitism
islamophobia all these attitudes that
have
uh prov have well contributed to what
happened on january 6. uh yeah islam by
by the way anti-semitism is totally fine
so long as members of her own party
propagating it and that's that's totally
cool by the way according to nancy
pelosi so we should just make that clear
what the january 6 commission is pretty
obviously designed to do again it's a
political maneuver
there's a reason why it is open-ended
there is a reason why it is supposed to
now delve into the ideological causes
of of january 6th and try to link that
to broader republican
talking points liz cheney if she
provides cover for that sort of report
is doing a grave disservice if liz
cheney is going in there because what
she wants to do
is is use the january 6 commission to
get to the bottom
of false allegations about voter fraud
and the impact that has
you know i again i think that she's
providing cover to democrats and it's a
mistake but at least you can understand
it but the report that comes out of that
commission
is all about how the republican party is
rife with white supremacy anti-semitism
and islamophobia and anyone who voted
for trump
obviously agrees with those things
because then trump went on to say stupid
things about the vote
in november and then a bunch of morons
and droogs decided to
utilize those words and twist them in
order to enter the capital building
if that's what that report ends up being
and liz cheney is just there to provide
cover then she's done a grave disservice
kevin mccarthy seems to he seems to
think this is exactly what's going on
here is the house minority leader
do you believe that effectively by liz
cheney accepting
it comedian simon on january 6 that
she's left the republican conference
i was shocked that she would accept
something from speaker pelosi
it would seem to me as since i didn't
hear from her maybe she's closer
to her than us i don't know okay so
apparently she never even spoke to
mccarthy about it which is again sort of
a weird move on on liz cheney's part i'm
not sure exactly
what her what her play here is meanwhile
again all of this is designed to
distract from the fact that the white
house
has some problems unattended so the
white house had a mediocre job report
said say mediocre because some parts of
it are good and
some parts of it are not so good but
it's certainly not like a universally
bad jobs
report according to the associated press
in an encouraging burst of hiring
america's employers added 850
000 jobs in june well above the average
of the previous three months and a sign
that companies may be having an easier
time finding enough workers to fill open
jobs
well except for the fact that there is
still this massive demand for jobs and
people aren't filling them
fast enough i don't know who this kind
of pull of economist is who decide how
many jobs they think are going to be
added or how they come to those numbers
uh but they've been wrong pretty much
every single month for the last several
so the fact that they underestimated
here where they've overestimated the
past few months
i like who cares the real question is
how fast are we filling the jobs
the real question is how fast is the
economy recovering
and the real question is what's the
unemployment rate are people coming back
into the workforce
wages rose pretty significantly which
again seems to demonstrate
that inflation is taking hold not only
that
the unemployment rate apparently
actually rose a little bit meaning fewer
people
are actually still getting back into the
workforce they're not feeling the pinch
necessary for them to actually go back
and work anymore friday's report from
the labor department was the latest sign
according to the ap
that the reopening of the economy is
propelling a powerful rebound from the
pandemic recession
restaurant traffic across the country is
nearly back to pre-pandemic levels
more people are shopping traveling
attending sports and entertainment
events the number of people flying each
day has regained about 80 percent of its
pre-coveted 19 levels americans
confidence in the economic outlook has
nearly fully recovered and of course
that is because the pandemic
is effectively over right if you're if
you're unvaccinated it's not over for
you
but if you're vaccinated then it's
certainly over for you and the rates
of people getting and dying of covet in
the united states are very very low
at this point so that has nothing to do
with joe biden's economic stimulus that
has to do with the fact that people are
now going back to work
the result is that many businesses are
desperate to hire and have posted a
record high
number of jobs with the competition for
workers intensifying especially at
restaurants and tourists and
entertainment venues
employers are offering higher pay along
with signing and retention bonuses and
more flexible hours
the unemployment rate actually rose from
5.8 percent in may to 5.9 percent
in june despite the job market's steady
improvement unemployment remains well
above the 3.5 percent rate that prevail
before the pandemic struck
the economy reigned 6.8 million jobs
short of its pre-pandemic levels
the number of advertised job openings
reached 9.3 million
in april so by the way the number of job
listings has actually increased since
then
so we still have a systemic problem that
the systemic problem is that we're
paying people to stay home
and this is leading to some pretty
severe issues
in regards to staffing so it is a good
thing
that that we have more people who are
getting jobs it is a very bad thing that
the
labor market is artificially shortages
are now being artificially created in
the labor market and inflation is
hitting by the way the white house has
pushed back on the inflation talking
point just sucks right now the white
house put out a tweet yesterday trying
to demonstrate inflation is not a
problem for families
even though the price of gas is up like
40 over last year
the white house put out a tweet saying
planning a cookout this year
ketchup on the news uh-huh it's a pun
according to the farm bureau the cost of
a fourth of july barbecue is down from
last year
it's a fact you must heared must heard
hot dog the biden economic plan is
working and that's something we can all
relish
um so how how well is it working the
cost of a fourth of july cookout in 2021
is down at 16 cents from last year
you may remember we had a meat shortage
last year because we're in the middle of
a pandemic
wow i mean look at that huge the cost
of a fourth of july cookout down 16
cents i mean my goodness
back in joe biden's day that could buy
you two packs of camels and
a stick of wrigley's chewing gum huge
i'm old enough to remember by the way
when the democrats claimed that hundreds
of dollars in your pocket thanks to
trump tax cuts meant nothing to the
average american family now they're
attending a 16 cent
decline in the price of basic food
stuffs for your fourth of july barbecue
even though pretty much the price on
everything else has skyrocketed
for basic necessities meanwhile the
budget deficit is projected to hit three
trillion dollars
according to the new york times the u.s
economy is rebounding from the pandemic
downturn faster than expected
is an entre and is on track to regain
all the jobs lost by the middle of next
year
partly as a result of enormous amounts
of federal spending that will push the
budget deficit to three trillion dollars
for the 2021
fiscal year according to the cbo new
forecasts that incorporate the 1.9
trillion dollar stimulus package
president biden signed into law give
little credence to warnings by
republican lawmakers and some economists
that runaway inflation from all that
spending could the economy
instead the budget office predicted a
recent spike in prices for cars airline
tickets other products would be
temporary and begin to recede
this year administration officials
downplayed the deficit projections
instead they focused on the predictions
for economic growth because gdp
is it can be gamed by simply injecting
government spending into the system
if the government spends a lot of money
that goes into the gdp
so you can gain those gdp stats by
simply inflating the currency
by providing easy credit by providing
loose credit
that all of that is a way to
artificially boost the economy and
create what
is in fact a fairly massive bubble and
this is as i have been warning one of
the big problems here a lot of people on
the right are focused in on the
inflation issue
inflation may turn into a systemic
long-term issue it is just as possible
maybe more possible
that what we are in fact going to get is
a steady sort of stagflation or a steady
deflation in which the government keeps
pumping money trying to provide loans
and people don't want to take the loans
because
people just aren't buying they've kind
of maxed out this is what we are
like there are a bunch of conflicting
signs right now in the economy according
to the new york times again same day
office vacancies soar in new york a dire
sign for the city's recovery
nearly 19 percent of all office space in
manhattan has no
tenants the highest on record according
to
matthew hogg even as new york city
reopens and pursues a long road to
economic recovery the pandemic's lasting
legacy of a changing workplace is
emerging as a major obstacle to the
revival of the vital commercial
districts that help fuel the city's
economy
across manhattan 18.7 percent of all
office space is available for lease
a jump from more than 15 at the end of
2020 and more than double the rate from
before the pandemic according to newmark
a real estate services company meanwhile
we also know that the restaurant grant
program that was put out by the federal
government
turned into kind of a boondoggle a 28.6
billion
federal relief fund for restaurants and
other food businesses closed on
wednesday after running out of money
having fulfilled fewer than a third of
the grant requests it received it turns
out that
even the attempt to fill in the gaps
created by the pandemic were a failure
as soon as government
got involved more than 370 000 business
owners applied for more than 75 billion
in funding nearly three times what the
program had available
around 105 000 businesses were approved
for grants which averaged just over 272
thousand dollars which of course is
going to support a restaurant with
several workers for like five minutes
uh so yeah again all of the stimulus was
directed in the wrong
direction well the good news is that the
united states is focused globally on
making business less competitive
in order to shore up the fact that the
united states is creating new
regulations and new taxes for businesses
we are trying to cudgel countries around
the world into raising their own taxes
on corporations which will result in
price inflation when you artificially
boost the tax
prices on corporations they're going to
pass that down to consumers so get ready
to feel the crunch that way
so mixed record coming from the biden
administration on the economy at best
at best they got to cover that with
something because 2022 lurks around the
corner
and the biden administration's policies
have not in fact forwarded economic
recovery
it suppressed economic recovery if they
just got out of the way they'd be much
better off
but they can't because it runs counter
to joe biden's lbj type
world beating agenda alrighty we'll be
back here later today with an additional
hour of the ben shapiro show first
you cannot forget to end your week check
out the andrew clavin show drew's shows
every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you so head on over
to dailywire.com at 7pm eastern 6 pm
central tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pablo wydowski
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin